about a couple days before in the office
we were working and a couple of
cosplayers there was a Zenyatta and I
believe there might have been a maybe it
was a mercy was actually in the office
they were friends of some the people and
they were just you know seeing zenyatta
walking through the office literally I
don't know I just it was just like great
a great feeling I and the costumes were
really amazing and we did I did ask the
cosplayers I was like tell us if there
was anything you would change in the
design being a cosplayer I think was
actually one of the cosplayers that had
a Reaper costume right and he said can
you give us more pockets so we could but
that's a new thing
yeah and I'm really summer to put his
phone yeah he's like can you give me
like a couple pockets where like that's
good that's really good
hi I'm Daniel Dwyer first I just want to
say thank you so much for watching our
three-part series on the story of
overwatch in this our final episode we
focus on the 21 playable characters in
blizzards latest game the heroes of this
game split into four classes of defense
offense support and tanks these folks
run the gambit from melee focused
eight-man to Zen robots Russian snipers
and Australian pyromaniacs but how do
you make a game which allows this many
character combinations where do you find
inspiration from where do you draw the
line and what happens and you find out
one of them is broken
in today's video without getting into
exhaustive detail I talked to the
designers and artists behind overwatch
about the process of creating the game's
21 heroes presumably every time the hero
team starts to like give people new
object new abilities and whatnot it like
causes you Mike bears I imagine right
sometimes yeah so early on the project I
had a conversation with Jeff Goodman
he's kind of our principal hero designer
and the guy's amazing at what he does
and he let me know that one day it
wasn't on our initial list of heroes one
day we will have a flying hero that can
go anywhere they want to in these maps
which was sort of a terrifying thing for
me to think about at the time but it's
like one walk rocks all over again
they put flying man saying yeah that's
that brings back some memories actually
yeah so it's a little bit like that
where I kind of realized early on that
that these maps were gonna have to
support a lot of different functions for
Heroes there were quite a few that made
some pretty serious changes over time I
mean it also ranges up how they change
so character like Farah came from a
gameplay concept or like well she was
one of the earliest ones well we all
love rocket launchers like we should
just put a rocket launcher in the game
so the character is built around our
rocket launchers like a what makes a
rocket launcher really cool well big
above people's realizes got the splash
damage and everything so what we build
on that and it kind of went from there
so we had like a really rough prototype
in there
Bera for instance like you said air
superiority we you know Jeff Goodman
a principal designer he was thinking of
a character that had a jet a jetpack and
a rocket launcher and those were the two
main criteria and we went through dozens
of concepts for fair and you know at one
point we called it the rocket Queen
that's like our code name for more time
at one point he was rocket dude
Arnold saying came up with like a whole
like a bunch of different ideas and the
kind of threw him up there for ever to
discuss and we had you know guy looking
like Tom Cruise at one point and he had
like a and it was just so many it was
great I mean that I loved that they
could do that and to have all these
different ideas and so that one was
definitely originating from a design
standpoint my character like Zarya for
instance is just a character that we
really wanted to do you know big strong
female character with a big gun and you
know design took that archetype and
found an awesome kid for for her based
around the the art that we made we
should do a cybernetic monk and then
earn our Elite League really concept
artists like drew a picture of them and
everyone was like yes we're going to do
that yeah that's like and then we
figured out what a cybernetic monk was
and was like what he shoes these energy
balls then has a yin-yang buff debuff
thing and then occasionally he becomes
one with the universe
okay go but the the character that we
actually used as an RD character to
develop the art style was actually torn
and it's interesting because like I was
saying about marrying the old and the
new tor Buren kind of sits like right in
the middle there where you know
blizzards known for World of Warcraft
you got your dwarf characters and that
was a place that we thought we could
start and you know see where we could
bring that archetype and push that layer
on with like this near future tech so
you take a character like Genji and
Genji as you guys have seen early on we
had concepts of him real early and so we
had this idea all the time we're going
to build him we had like a really rough
prototype what it could be I'm Hanzo and
Genji they were at one point one
character that we just called Hanzo and
he had like a bow get a sword yet in the
stars he had all kind of like the ninja
samurai archetype is so interesting to
me and you know the team just loves that
that that themes once we got in there
and started tuning in trying to make it
work like it was an almost impossible
situation for us because it's very
difficult to make sort of an assassin
sort of high-damage character with a
melee weapon only in a game where every
was shooting you all the time
so he probably did the most changing
internally at one point he had
invisibility and he was like its back
stabbing people and killing them
instantly and that obviously all went
out the window and so we decided oh what
if they're like these strange brothers
and we can have a sword and the bow and
we've been attacking all these different
themes for both of them and now had like
having their story fleshed out I think
it was it was really exciting it's it's
a always tries with people in the press
try make these types of comparisons but
there are like one or two characters
which almost seem like like commentary
on or like references to other games
that exist within the space so when I
see Deva for instance like it reminds me
a lot of titanfall it's a game I read
out and then for soldier 76 is the
funniest thing ever because it's
literally like he's named soldier 76 and
it is like shift is his move is like
running isn't the shift button like are
you guys sort of enjoying those little
those little archetypes in the game the
hero design discussions are a blast
those initial ones what's just free
willing but it's just like a soldier 76
was a hero we basically designed after a
play test like one night and it was like
you know we really need that hero that
really speaks to people that have like
been playing a whole lot of Call of Duty
yeah something that you know sometime
people like you know especially because
I'm in a lot of our potential our
younger players they didn't have they
didn't play Team Fortress way back in
the day like most the first person or
the modern military style shooters were
like hey but you know so what would that
what would the hero look like so well we
have it I saw it was like okay we get
this all rifle and then it's like well
yeah we want to like speak more towards
like you know someone you know it's very
easy to understand it's like hey what's
another thing to give them oh well the
the rocket launcher on cooldown it's
like right there we go it's like right
that's that's another one they were like
okay well if something everyone like
when they first play this game is what
why can't I have sprint okay we'll give
this guy's sprint or that's cool
and then we started coming with a crazy
ideas for Ultimates and they were like
what if we like Auto and were like wow
because we were like well we we gave
Widowmaker the ability to see through
walls this is give like another like
traditional FPS sheet or character is
called an alternate um and that's what
we did and that literally all came
together probably like that that seed of
like that hero like it one night and I
just sort of like clicked something that
cemented a hero like that it's like
comes together super fast and you know
and then there's your ambassador who's
had a bit more of like a lot more
changes like to him like over
I think he's gone through we've got this
money Holtz I know you remember now I
want to say six different notes or
something eternally he was literally
like flying at one point he had like
almost like feral like jets and you know
he could shoot through walls launch of
volleys and grenades up in the air we
premiered him at close con with like a
little drone tank drone thing so you
know into the Marriott what he has now
which is great because it fits really
well with his transformation kit where
he's got this third super form that's
just like he only gets to do
occasionally and it's like the ultimate
version of what he already does so I'm
ended up working all directions but we
didn't want to just sort of toss out
this this ultimate they'd had before
even though it didn't work for him it
was a lot of fun so we liked it it just
didn't really work for his character so
by the time we got around to working on
road hog and junk rat you know we had to
all this opportunity in drunk rat jack
rat to make his his rip tire ultimate
which is sort of a different version of
that the old call back that he remember
the explosive mine concept that we had a
bastion which fits chuck rat much better
both in gameplay and the character and
everything just sort of worked out great
there so I think that's an example where
we were able to like really use
something that didn't make the cut
another character for him the great
effect the team has spent years working
these characters into the form we now
see chipping away at their rock cutting
parts from others and drawing
inspiration from everything and anything
the result is a strong set of characters
that even players like me folks who
usually stick to one or two classes
enjoy doubling with hero swapping
mid-game is part of how you play
overwatch and finding your role within
the team is critically important but
recently there was some backlash in
relation to the editing of one of the
characters in-game poses the online
debate that followed had little to do
with overwatch itself and more to do
with battling personal opinions on the
historically poor representation of
female characters in video games and
what some see as content censorship so
considering the news had just broke when
I was interviewing Jeff I thought I'd
allow him the opportunity to respond for
himself
can you talk to the decision earlier
this week to remove tracers or to edit
tracers pose and from the game and the
sort of communication you guys have with
your users on the message boards and
stuff like that absolutely and so we
made a decision we had a post called
over the shoulder for tracer that we
were never really pleased with there
just from an artistic standpoint it was
one of those ones where we always felt
kind of fell outside of the character's
personality traceurs cute and playful
and she's the type of person who kind of
does everything with a wink and a smile
and in the pose she takes herself very
seriously it's one of these like
traditional almost supermodel poses is
how I would describe it and there was an
interesting discussion had evolved on
our forums talking about issues that one
of our posters had that like this pose
made him feel a little bit uncomfortable
because his daughter really looked up to
tracer and felt like this was kind of a
pose that that wasn't entirely
appropriate so it was kind of those two
things together the fact that we were
never really happy with the pose and we
felt like it fell out of character and
the fact that some of our community
members were saying you know like hey we
think you guys might have crossed the
line in terms of appropriateness with
this that helped influence our decision
you know hey we have a better pose
anyway a really cool cute playful
over-the-shoulder pose so it's still an
over-the-shoulder pose that we kind of
should have gone with in the first place
why don't we just use that pose instead
it felt like a win-win to us I felt like
I had communicated the situation pretty
poorly on the forums I like to get in
very early in the morning and I'd like
to answer as many forum threads as I can
very quickly I go about my day and then
I come back usually late at night and
answer a few more forum threads just so
our players know that we're listening
that we're interacting with them and
that was one where I really didn't put
much thought into my response and it was
really wrong of me to on a topic that I
should have known was a sensitive one to
explain our reasoning behind the
decision more so people had an
understanding you know the part that
upset me was that people questioned our
artistic integrity and called it
censorship I mean censorship to me is
when somebody comes to me as as the game
director I have the final creative say
on anything
that goes into the game and censorship
to me is when somebody comes and tells
me I need to remove something from the
game and those moments happen like
that's a reality that exists in video
games that's not at all what happened
here what happened here was me as the
final creative say over the game said we
have such a cooler better pose this
one's obviously ruffling some feathers
look this is an easy simple decision but
I didn't communicate it that way with
our players so it became I think it
became a bigger deal than it needed to
be and that fault was on me
and I'm sort of sorry to our community
members on both sides of the argument
whichever way that they felt about it
because I feel like it was sort of this
unnecessary drama when all said and done
though and probably at the time that
people are hearing about this it's
probably blown over at this point
I feel like if the most controversial
thing to come out of overwatch beta is a
single pose of one of our characters
I'll take that any day over hey I don't
think the game is fun or it's not cool
or blizzard did something really bad so
you know in in the grand scheme of drama
and drama that's inevitably going to
happen I guess this is not the worst
thing in the world to happen these are
care about their characters their heroes
in the world of overwatch and this can
also be seen in the way they tell the
story of this world there is no
singleplayer story led campaign in
overwatch but the team at Blizzard have
attempted to subtly express the
narrative of the game world via
environmental storytelling and some
impressive animated shorts you know
we've sort of been trying to tell the
story of overwatch in this way that's a
little different than how we usually do
we've really been trying not to over
explain things over figure out like what
we already have we've been figuring it
out piece by piece with each hero with
each map with each story we're trying to
tell and slowly we're sort of building
this tapestry of what the story is and
it's been really interesting because
it's it's been a really natural process
it feels a little bit like archaeology
like we're you know we have these things
we feel really strongly about and then
as we put them together or as we dig
them out more we start to see
connections that we
plan for but once we see them like how
will that of course that makes sense and
you know of course you know Winston and
tracer were friends and they went on all
these adventures and you know that's
that's sort of the organic process that
we've been going with for overwatch you
know our hope has been that these
episodes we've been working on which is
just one of the funnest projects we've
done in years that they fill in enough
not necessarily like you know the the
perfect scope of the world but are just
these very distinct short stories that
kind of feel any like ah I get it I get
the tone I get this world as it's you
know we're I think next week the the
next episode comes out which is based on
Widowmaker and it's it's it's much
darker than the first one it's almost
the extreme of the gamut of tone and
theme that overwatch is inherently based
on so I'm totally fascinated to see what
people think and how does that fill out
their picture of the world you know more
than just Widowmaker or whoever's
involved in that episode how does it
make them feel and what kind of new
questions does it get them to ask you
know about this unfolding tapestry
that's kind of what's fun about it you
know it doesn't feel tracked it doesn't
feel like we're on a you know it's it's
just the highways completely open for us
to explore themes and ideas and it's
super liberating one thing we wanted to
try was what if we don't just fill in
all the blanks you know what if we don't
just give you a big timeline and say you
know here are all the big important
things that happen here are the you know
explicit interactions between the
characters that are in their history and
we want people to sort of experience
these different parts and to start to
form their own opinions like solve some
of these mysteries we put out there like
there's a certain sort of almost like a
collaboration that we're having with the
community therefore we we give them some
things we see what they're interested in
it might inspire us but I think that we
have a number of tools do this so
obviously we have the game world and
throughout the game world we're able to
put little hints in in the way that the
art is you know presented the way kind
of like the decorations that we put
around the map the things characters say
it's quite limited you know one or two
sentences back and forth but in that you
start to get the wave characters feel
about each other they can respond to
events that are happening in the
universe and we start to kind of peel
the layers off and show you what's going
on underneath the surface and that's it
thank you so much for watching the story
of overwatch a three-part series on
blizzards first new game world in 17
years we do hope you enjoyed this little
peek into how overwatch was crafted and
for continuing coverage of overwatch as
well as thousands of other video games
make sure you subscribe to this channel
or visit GameSpot comm thanks we'll see
you next time
armored over
okay
know what
you